buckingham palace is addressing
diversity issues
head-on the queen's statement made it
very clear that you're not going to
hear probably from the palace she wants
to
take this issue in-house deal with it
in private um within the family
according to a royal source
the palace is considering hiring a
diversity czar in the wake of prince
harry and
meghan markle's shocking claims during
their oprah winfrey interview that aired
earlier this month
i think it is very much the case that
she wants to
she wants to smooth things over and this
is not only being catastrophic for the
royal family in the public eye
don't forget behind closed palace doors
there are deep rifts that
are right at the heart of the royal
family
the queen is in her twilight years now
she's coming to the end of her reign the
source adds that in the coming weeks
there will be a listen
and learn approach about how practices
may be improved to include more
representation
quote it is something that has to be
considered but it is too early for any
firm plans to be announced
we are listening and learning to get
this right the source notes that
diversity is something that the royal
family takes
seriously and adds that more can always
be done
the monarchy is all about unity and this
fragmentation this this rupture these
riffs at the center of it
i'm not doing the monarchy any good in
the 90-minute special with oprah
both the duke and duchess of sussex
claimed there was concern about how dark
their son archie's skin might be when he
was born
while they didn't reveal who in the
royal family initiated those
conversations
oprah revealed on cbs this morning that
harry
did confirm it was not his grandmother
queen elizabeth ii
or his grandfather prince philip the
queen wants to sort it out
she wants to see harry she wants to see
her great-grandchildren
and i think the feeling is that while
she's going to be firm
and she's totally going to investigate
what was said in this conversation this
private conversation
she is also going to treat the sussexes
with kindness following the couple's
explosive interview
the palace released an official
statement saying that they were saddened
to learn how challenging the last few
years have been for megan and harry
adding quote the issues raised
particularly that of race
are concerning while some recollections
may vary
they are taken very seriously and will
be addressed by the family privately
meanwhile megan and harry are focusing
on archwell an
organization they started to help drive
systemic cultural change
through the power of compassion et has
learned that archwell
is growing in fact the couple has hired
ben browning
as their head of content the celebrated
producer was recently nominated for an
oscar for his work on promising young
[Music]
women